Vanessa Hudgens under fire for making
insensitive comments amid the corona
virus outbreak it all started when the
High School Musical actress did an
Instagram live with fans on Monday and
seemingly responded to a fan who asked
if she thought the effects of the
disease would last till July yeah til
July it sounds like a bunch of bull I'm
sorry but like it's a virus I get it
like I respect it but at the same time
like even if everybody gets it like yeah
people are gonna die it's just terrible
but like the clip went viral for all the
wrong reasons
and now Vanessa is apologizing first in
a series of videos on her Instagram
story Tuesday hey guys so yesterday I
did an Instagram live and I realized
today that some of my comments are being
taken out of context it's a crazy time
it's a crazy crazy time and I am at home
and in lockdown and that's what I hope
you guys are doing to in full quarantine
and staying safe and sane yeah I don't
take the situation lightly by any means
I'm home
so stay inside y'all later in the day
Vanessa issued another apology this time
in writing on Twitter she said in part
quote I realized my words were
insensitive and not at all appropriate
for the situation our country and the
world are in right now Vanessa went on
to acknowledge the impact of her words
and sent her best wishes for everyone to
stay safe and healthy meanwhile several
stars have used their platform to spread
messages of positivity safety and
wellness like Matthew McConaughey let's
take care of ourselves and each other
let's not go to the lowest common
denominator and get paranoid let's do
our due diligence take the precautions
we
to take care of ourselves and those of
us around us right now more than ever
before we're all more dependent on each
other than we ever have been we have an
enemy in corona virus that is faceless
that is raceless sexless
nondenominational and bipartisan and
it's an enemy that we all agree we want
to be want to be and we're gonna beat
him Arnold Schwarzenegger sent us this
friendly reminder with a little help
from his furry friends one thing is that
you stay at home because there's a
curfew now it's like 72 years old after
65 unit a lot of the house and in my
california so we stay home and be in
here oh yes yummy with the whiskey and
this mu nu loves carrots whiskey loves
carrots I just had my little be the
vegan and never one to mince words
Hilary Duff gave us a message to stand
for to all you young Millennials that
keep going out and partying go home stop
killing all the people please
[Music]